بعد 73 عاما من انشائي خطي انابيب
التبلاين في منطقه الحدود الشماليه
السعوديه بدا العمل على تفكيك خط الانابيب
الذي لعب دورا محوريا طوال 40 عاما في نقل
النفطي عبر الصحراء من بقيق شرق السعوديه
وحتى مينا صيد في لبنان اذكروا ان خط
الانابيب الذي سجل لك اول موقع لتراث
الصناعي في السعوديه توقف عن ضخ النفط منذ
عام 1990
خطه انابيب التاب لاين روايه نجاح سعودي
امتدت ما تدفق الذهب الاسود من الدقيق شرق
السعوديه الى ميناء صيدا على البحر الابيض
المتوسط وصولا الى الاسواق العالميه حيث
لاعبه دورا محوريه بمد اوروبا بالطاقه على
مدى اربعه عقود قبل ان يتم ايقافه عن
الضغط عام 1990
من شخوص هذه الروايه محمد القبلان الذي
جرى من عمره 30 عاما في محيط جريان النفط
عبر هذا الانبوب
عام
1947 بامر من الملك عبد العزيز رحمه الله
وانا عملته في من عام
1957 بوظيفه
الاقتصاديه وكذلك ابعاده اجتماعيه لان
التابلين
وفرق المياه
والمستشفيات والمدارس
وتكون التجمعات السكانيه بجوار التابرين
وعاشت من رفاهيه
[موسيقى]
هذا المشروع الصناعي الذي ظل ممتد من ثياب
على رمال الصحراء على مدى 73 عاما بدات
ارامكو حديثا بتفكيك اجزائه عدا الواقعه
قرب مدن محطات الدخل قديما كما عالم شاخصه
تحفظ مكانه اول موقع للتراث الصناعي مسجل
في السعوديه
[موسيقى]
اهميه كبيره وحفظ تاريخه للاجيال القادمه
صنعتها السعوديه منتصف القران الماضي
ازالته انابيب باحد اكبر مشاريع نقل النفط
عبر الصحراء في العالم تتم وفق عمليات
دقيقه وباليات متطوره وباشراف مباشر من
شركه ارامكو
من منطقه الحدود الشماليه
جزاعا ماصي العربيه
ومن جده ينضم الينا الرئيسيه لهيئه التراث
الدكتور جاسر الحربش دكتور جاسر مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
في ما يخص طبعا
هيئه التراث دكتور جاسر عن قصه الازاله
اولا عن الاحتفاظ باجزاء من هذا الخط خط
اكتب لاين ما الذي يمكن ان نعرف عنه
الشوكه مره ثانيه على تواصلكم دائما انت
وسيلتنا للتواصل مع المجتمع وسيله
الرئيسيه حقيقه والتقرير مميز بالاخ هزاع
واخونا ايضا الخبير محمد يتحدث في التقرير
كلها قدمت صراحه الخلفيه الممتازه اللي
نحتاجه بعض المعلومات اللي بقولها ففعلا
هو هو ال- ال- المشروع الوطني مشروع ضخم
وليس فقط مشروع صناعي بالمناسبه نحن دائما
نتحدث عن هذا المشروع انه ايضا مشروع رؤيه
واستثمار لانه في ذلك الوقت المبكر عندما
يعني طبقت الفكره بقيه المؤسس معك عبد
العزيز رحمه الله الان همم بعد تسجيل همم
العنصر تابلاين في موقع تراث عناصر السجل
التراث الصناعي الوطني وايضا ترشيح وضمن
ملف التراث الصناعي الوطني بشكل عام الذي
سيسجل في قائمه العامه
همم تم الاتفاق مع وزاره الطاقه وشركه
ارامكو على تفعيل عناصر كثير اكثر من 45
عنصر من ضمنها مثل ما ذكرته في التقرير
المميز من فقد ضحى الضخ حطتها الحمايه
وحرام كبير من التايب لاين سيبقى يحافظ
عليه ال- ال- الاجمل من هذا ان المواقع
التي سيتم المحافظه عليها ليست فقط ستبقى
وتحمي بل انها ستفعل سيضع في موقع الان
بدانا العمل فيه في مرحله الدراسات
والتصاميم في عرعر وان شاء الله انه يعني
اشرح لي هالنبه
ناخذ موقع مثلا موقع حاليا المحطه اللي
موجوده في عرعر الان نحن نعمل على تصاميم
مع مع شركه عالميه بمعالجه التراث الصناعي
العالميه ايضا مع الشركاء المحليين ان
يحول هذا المبنى الى مركز زوار يحكي قصه
التاب لاين قصه المواطنين المواطنين الذين
عملوا فيه واثر على حياتهم ايضا القصه قصه
التوثيق المخاطبات الوثائق كل ما لدى
الشركات والجهات والمشاركه سيعرض سيطرد
يعني
لن يزال بكامله في اجزاء ستبقى ضبط بالضبط
في كل تاكيد وهذا هذا هو العمل اللي يعني
استغرق تقريبا سنتين من بدايه العمل مع
الزملاء في وزاره الطاقه وشركه ارامكو تم
الاتفاق على مخطط كامل واعتماده من من
الخبر دوليين يعملون في اليونسكو وسيتم
التصرف بعض الاجزاء ولكن الجزء الاهم وهي
المحطات والعناصر اللي عدتها 45 هو باقي
مثل ما قلت ليس الباقي فقط كان حمايه صحيح
من نظر لوحات نضع بعض نقاط الحمايه لكن
المهم هو انه بفعل بيكون فيه يعني مثل ما
يعني مثل ما تروح الان انتم ضيوفك الحيه
طريف مركز زوار الجميل اللي موجود في
الدرعيه الضيوف اللي بيزورون مثلا حدود
الشماليه بيكون احد نقاط الرئيسيه للزياره
عندهم ال- ال- مركز زواره خاصه الذي يحكي
القصه بكاملها ويكون شغاله على طول السنه
وليس مرتبط بفعاليه
احنا طبعا 45 حافظنا عليها لكن احنا نتحدث
عن يعني الرؤيه القريبه القريبه يعني
استنى سنتين القادمه نتحدث عن خمس مواقع
ان شاء الله للمنطقه الشرقيه نصيب منطقه
حدود الشماليه نصيب والاهم من هذا انها
تقدم بشكل جاذب يحكي القصه يحكي اثر هذا
مشروع الضخم وفي وثائق ضخمه جدا يعني
الزملاء فيها في وزاره الطاقه يعني بلغونا
عنكم تحت تصرفنا الموضوع الصور بعض مقاطع
الفيديو الوثائق التي تنشر لي اول مره
ايضا التراث المحكيه يعني انتم يعني
تقريبا مميز وصلت الاحد اهم مصادر الطره
المحكمه الاخ محمد القبلان وهناك تسجيلات
هناك منهم على قيد الحياه الله يرحمه لكن
كل عملنا الان في المشروع الذي يعمل
بشراكه معي اماره المنطقه الحدود الشماليه
ومع وزاره الطاقه من جهه وشركه ترامكو
وواقي الشركان المحليين طبعا
عليها من وزاره الطاقه
سواء انشاء هذه
ال- ال- المحطه او كيف كانت تعمل
والمشاركين فيها او الصوره يعني او
المستندات حتى الرسميه ستكون في هذه
المواقع الخمسه اللي ذكرتها للزوار متاخر
اي اي اي يعني وثيقه او صوره او فيديو
يعني هينا اجراءات النظاميه لعرضه فسيعرض
الزملاء متعاوني مجزره الطاقه وكل الشركاء
وانا متاكد حتى للاهاليوم يعني لديهم عدد
من الوثائق اللي تشرفنا احنا بعرضها ونضع
عليها اسمهم من هذه الوثيقه قدمت من
المواطن او المواطنه بالاسم المحدد مثل ما
نعمل في كل همم يعني اسالي بداراتنا تراث
الثقافي دائما كلنا يا اخوي ومع الزملاء
في مسلسل رابعه انشاءنا التراث الثقافي هو
شان لي شان هيا حكوميه فقط هو شان مجتمع
عشان شركاء عشان رساله نحن نوصلها ونشاركم
معنا يعني انا اجتها فرصه يعني تقريركم
هذا يعطينا فرصه اننا ندعو مره ثانيه لانه
في يعني جهه او او فرد ااا او مؤسسه او او
قطاع خاص قطاع عام قطاع غير ربحي عنده
معلومات او عنده رغبه او عنده قدره انه
يشارك في المشروع العظيم هذا تشرفنا
بالعمل فيه من خلال المنظومه وزاره
الثقافه هيئه التراث بالمناسبه يمكن ان
نسيت اقول شيء مهم انه يوجد جمعيه اسست
جمعيه للتراث الصناعي الان نحن نعمل على
اعاده تشكيله
ايضا بعض
المواقع الهامه التي كانت شاهد على همم
يعني همم التنميه الصناعيه التي بدات
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه ممكن على راسها
بلايين كاول موقع تراثي